prêt pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs
secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
des bouches du rhône bonsoir frédéric
jeanjean merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés nicolas vidal éditorialistes
bonsoir nicolas vidal
enfin arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être là
donc des dîners à un montant qui serait
organisée à paris dans des restaurants
clandestins en pleine pandémie n'en
fallait pas plus pour mettre le feu aux
poudres vous piètre fermé depuis des
mois au frédéric jeanjean comment vous
recevez cette information déjà ce que
nous entendons c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un restaurant traditionnel puisqu'il
s'agit du palais y viennent domicile de
monsieur chalencon et que s'il s'agit
d'un club privé
donc ça c'est la première chose il est
évident que les soirées privées c'est ce
que nous dénonçons depuis près d'un an
avait la fermeture des discothèques
c'est ce que nous dénonçons aussi avec
la fermeture de nos établissements et
que nous n'avons eu de cesse de dire
qu'il vaut mieux que nous puissions
travailler avec un protocole strict
encadré et que l'on sache ce que l'on
fait plutôt que de laisser tout le vent
de fermer parce que la nature étant ce
qu'elle est on ne pourra pas empêcher
les gens de se regrouper et de se
retrouver et ou plus les temps qui vaut
ce qui viennent vont être agréable doit
être ensoleillé au plus de la loire ce
genre de manifestation de regroupement
c'est naturel c'est humain ça c'est la
première réflexion après qu'il s'agisse
de pierre paul jacques ou gens qui se
retrouvent
on subit tous en ce moment cet effet il
faut qu'on soit tous solidaires ça c'est
la deuxième réflexion qui vient est en
fait la véritable question que je
poserai ça fait un an que nous subissons
cet état de fait dans toute la france ça
fait un an qu'on nous dit que nous
subissons cela pour éviter que l'hôpital
de son intention
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis un an
pour éviter que l'hôpital le soir en
tension et là on arrive sur un terrain
peu plus politique mais il faut quand
même posé la question est ce qu'on est
arrivé est ce qu'on a prévu
qu'il y ait ne passerelle qui soit
établie entre le public et le privé où
est-ce qu'on reste sur les diktats de
l'école de nantes l'école des hautes
études en santé publique qui veut qu'il
n'y ait que le public au coeur du public
point de salut est ce qu'on a prévu
quelque chose avec l'armée avec un
service de santé quand même assez
conséquent est ce qu'on apprenne
d'ouverture de lits des formations de
personnel je ne sais pas en fait depuis
un an à long terme au début on
comprenait que ont été pris de court le
plus au nord qu'est ce qui a été proposé
on nous parle la vaccination est depuis
le début ça patine un peu ça tarde à
démarrer
alors là il ya aussi de l'agacement
arnaud benedetti alors c'est vrai que ce
qui fera pas évidemment dans ce
reportage
c'est forcément vendeur les soirées un
peu spécial caviar champagne les menus
allant de 260 ha à plus de 450 euros
mais il faut quand même être honnête
tout le monde sait en france qui a pas
que ce type de restaurant qui restent
ouverts il ya des bistrots beaucoup plus
modeste donc on va pas faire mine de
l'ignorer mais il n'empêche ça fait
désordre aujourd'hui en pleine polémique
alors que le gouvernement nous impose
des restrictions qui sont parfois
extrêmement compliqué à accepter ça va
laisser des traces alors on rappelle
qu'une enquête est en cours et qui a eu
un peu rétro pédalage on ne sait pas
encore si vous au nom des ministres y
ont assisté mais le mal est fait en tout
cas ça va laisser des traces dans
l'opinion avec déjà une vraie défiance
envers les pouvoirs publics ça va le
faire que renforcer un sentiment qui
existe depuis fort longtemps ce qui
n'est pas lié d'ailleurs à la crise
sanitaire avec eux la crise sanitaire
peut-être à travers ce type d'image ne
fait qu'accentuer il y à une défiance
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des élites vers le
visa ville du haut de la société toutes
les études d'opinion depuis maintenant
un certain nombre d'années montrent que
les françaises et les français
considèrent qu' il y a disons un deux
poids deux mesures qui existent dans la
société française avec des élites
sociales économiques politiques qui
seraient en voie de cession par rapport
au reste de la société d'ailleurs c'est
une réalité objective aussi quand on
regarde un certain nombre
certain nombre de chiffres il suffit de
voir par exemple que paris aujourd'hui
ce 45 40 % des cadres supérieurs habite
paris alors qu'il n'ya plus que 9 %
d'ouvriers donc cette réalité de la
sécession social c'est un phénomène
sociologique qui toute façon est inscrit
profondément aujourd'hui malheureusement
dans la société française des images de
ce type le fond que le renforcer dans un
pays qui a subi une crise comme celle
des gilet jaune qui a été une crise
politique profondément marqué par un
sentiment anti élites
on voit bien que ce à quoi nous avons
assisté à travers ce reportage c'est le
sentiment qui se défera du frac que les
contraintes sanitaires ne seraient pas
les mêmes pour tout fait pour tous donc
les dégâts existait déjà par le passé
ils ne seront vraisemblement qu'un peu
plus renforcé aujourd'hui n'est plus ni
moins mais centre tait s'il voulait à
l'o2 de dissociation de distance
d'opposition par rapport aux
responsables quels qu'ils soient
avant de faire un gérant nicolas vidal
en face au tollé le parquet de paris on
l'a dit a ouvert une enquête beaucoup de
réactions politiques évidemment les
arrière pensées électorales sont
nécessairement à écouter celle de
bastien lachaud député de la france
insoumise suivi dont la france d'en haut
qui vit son masque où on va de déjeuner
au dîner clandestins se rient à gorge
déployée de voir des français subir
gentiment les restrictions le problème
n'est pas tant eux le problème c'est
notre docilité collective face à eux la
police verbalise la jeunesse populaire
quand elle ne porte pas son masque mais
les puissants trinquent dont les
restaurants ton destin
les pauvres et les étudiants font la
cure à l'aide alimentaire mais la caste
fait la fête dans ces soirées privées
qu'il dégage nicolas vidal
cette idée d'une france d'en haut qui
est ce serait au dessus des lois alors
qu'on nous fait la morale pour respecter
les
les restes gestes barrières et les
restrictions c'est ce qui va rester de
cette affaire même si peut-être qu'en
fait il n'y avait pas de ministre on
n'en sait rien l'enquète nous nous le
dira mais de mal est fait effectivement
c'est une politique pour moi qui ai
vraiment criant de 7,2 france et un en
belgique ne peut parler et le titre de
votre émission le dis aussi mais pour
moi vous savez c'est finalement cette
crise
cette polémique c'est finalement la
crise du coc vite 19 véhicules d'un côté
par les élites kérosène vous savez les
élites kérosène de son cher à jean
claude michéa et puis après vous avez la
flanc la fronde est déplorable
christophe guilluy vous avez forcément
ça va faire polémique ya une défiance
bien entendu envers une classe duo les
1% ce qu'on appelle le 1% les très aisés
qui finalement s'exonère de toutes les
règles sanitaires
on a vu de ce reportage de m6 la
question qui se pose est ce que c'est
une partie immergée de l'iceberg
ça c'est extrêmement important et il ya
ce moment là les français finalement ils
acceptent de moins en moins bien de
tenir ensemble et certains les ripailles
encore ensemble
vous avez sûrement vu cette photo qui
vient de montpellier depuis précisément
de la plage de la grande motte avec
cette amende qui a été dressé pour des
gens qui ont pris un peu l'air sur la
plage qui accomplit 400 euros pour que
mon port du masque et consommation avec
l'homme de dieu rosé dont vous imaginez
bien que ces exemples sont criants et
cette défiance eux continuent à monter
alors on comprend bien les jeux
politiques des uns et des autres mais
les français aujourd'hui sont au dessus
de ça et comme si ça continue à
cristalliser cette crise de la défiance
de la démocratie finalement il ya ceux
qui font ce qu'ils veulent et puis à les
autres et puis il ya une âme de grami
j'appellerais ça la gastronomie de
l'endogamie bien entendu c'est la
bamboche d'une république alternative
qui se moque des règles et en plus et en
plus on verra ce que dit l'enquète on
verra les suites de cette enquête
mais finalement on voit quelqu'un qui
s'exonèrent des règles de l'état donc ce
que même l'état
ces règles sont bafoués et ça ça devient
insupportable arno bertina l'apa relève
la crise des gis les jeunes c'est le
point de bascule effectivement de la
sédition d'une certaine partie dite
française et c'est chose d'à finalement
on voit que c'est des restaurants ou
lors des clubs privés ou des dîners
privés il ya quand même des menus des
tarifs des recommandations des
passe-droits des digicodes donc on voit
bien qu elle qui a une forme latente de
ganic et mais ça va pas remettre en
place la confiance entre les français
qui galèrent qui acceptent de moins en
moins bien vous le savez les mesures
sanitaires qui en ont marre qui sont là
qui peuvent pas sortir de chez eux de
l'a19
mais maintenant que les associations 10
km on imaginait que les français ils
n'en peuvent plus et que très nettement
cette polémique
elle va en fait y aller elle caractérise
cette société fragmentée fracturée voilà
un peu mon sentiment sur le premier
frédéric jeanjean vont qui connaissait
voilà qui est au coeur du réacteur c'est
vrai que là voilà c'est un peu facile et
on va essayer de ne pas tomber dans la
facilité forcément c'est de la
provocation ces beaux endroits ces
tarifs exorbitants mais on le fait en
france que je disais en début de 2 de ce
débat il ya beaucoup bistrot qui reste
ouvert c'est une grande partie votre
profession et ça évidemment ça crée une
disparité il ya les restaurateurs qui
respecte les règles qui tirent la langue
et ceux qui rient d'eau fermé voilà
ouvre dans l'ariège l'arrière-garde si
j'ose dire il y en a beaucoup
alors écoutez si on a beaucoup je sais
pas parce qu'il surmonte pas forcément
ça c'est la première chose ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je fais quand
même la différence entre les clients qui
vient de faire aux bombes au chaud par
emilienne d'une part et d'autre part le
restaurateur qui est un petit
établissement qui parfois passe à
travers les mailles de la raquette au
pouvoir avoir les aident et qui se
trouvent obligés de trouver des
solutions pour pouvoir s'en sortir on
pourra bouffer pour payer son loyer
moi je des restaurateurs ici qui
arrivent il travaille pas il faut des
plats à emporter du système d il y en a
qui ont résilié leur bail et ils vivent
dans le restaurant il ya des restaurants
où je rentre où vous avez les lits et
vous avez des gamins qui jouent là au
milieu alors s'il se mettait à
travailler à ouvrir moi je le
comprendrais tout à fait parce que y'a
un moment quand on est père ou mère de
famille et qu'on a des devoirs et qui
peut assumer
eh bien ça je le conçois tout à fait
vous savez c'est pas la première fois
que les gens se font attraper les
mangent au restaurant
rappelez vous la faire du tribunal de la
cour d'appel de paris où plusieurs
magistrats avaient été pris en flagrant
délit à table rappelez-vous dans le
canard enchaîné cet article nous
expliquer que j'avais une table et avec
les journalistes de bfm tv qui s'étaient
retrouvés avec en plus les conseillers
médicaux et scientifiques
qui venait d'expliquer qu'il fallait
loup fermé et respecter les gestes
barrières et qu'ils allaient manger dans
une arrière salle aussi donc vous avez
c'est nouveau mais je vous dis c'est
d'une manière générale c'est parce que
le fond du problème
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour qu'on
sorte de cette situation justement
arnaud benedetti sa pose bien sûr la
question de l'acceptabilité et c'est
intéressant les propos de frédéric
jeanjean tout d'abord avant de vous
faire réagir regarder ce sondage 1 ils
datent d'il ya quelques jours plus de
sept français sur dix approuvent eux les
principales mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron mais alors ce qui est
rigolo c'est la deuxième partie de ce
sondage à près d'un français sur deux
46% et plus de six jeunes sur dix compte
transgresser les règles on trouve ça
super mémés tout comme pas vraiment les
appliquer ces règles
ça veut dire que dans le fond se fait
justice soi même on se dit bah écoutez
on nous voit là c'est un peu injuste on
les accepte pas donc on les transgresse
les règles tout simplement et puis on
décide d'aller au restaurant si on se
sent pas vraiment en danger
c'est ça le fond de cette affaire au
final dans toutes les situations qui
relève des circonstances exceptionnelles
situations de guerre mais les situations
comme celle que nous connaissons de
crise pandémie que nous assistons
nécessairement à des dérèglements
humains qui sont j'allais dire presque
malheureusement naturel ce qui est su il
ya toujours eu dans les guerres des
profiteurs de guerre c'est un grand
classique de l'histoire
là ce qui est intéressant dans ce
sondage c'est que il révèle au grand
jour ce phénomène assez contradictoire
c'est que il ya une majorité de français
qui approuvent
après 70 % les mesures qui ont été
prises par emmanuel macro pour ce
confinement qui ne dit pas son nom
ce confinement numéro 3 et puis vous
avez quasiment une majorité ou presque
une majorité de français qui est disposé
à les transgresser et c'est évidemment
le la deuxième la deuxième question qui
est importante parce que celle ci dit
véritablement quel est l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui d'une partie de l'opinion
publique qui considère que est la plus
vraisemblable le mans a subi
les conséquences d'une crise sanitaire
qu'elle fuit les peaux dont elle sait
porter la responsabilité elle parfois à
raison on en v fonctionnement de l'état
alors le virus bien évidemment c'est une
chose personne ne l'avait prévu mais
après la façon dont on pouvait gérer ce
virus là il ya véritablement des
questions qui se posent sur la manière
dont l'état a mis en place sa politique
salutaire au courant justement mettre
fin à cette pandémie
les questions qui sont finalement les
questions essentielles celle du début de
la pandémie c'est à dire de mars dernier
ce restent les mêmes à ce stade vous
l'avez rappelé l'attention sur la
structure hospitalière pourquoi en
allant finalement n'avons pas nous
essayer de commencer à réarmer les
structures hospitalières pour faire face
pour faire face à des tensions à des
tensions salutaire la question des
moyens la question des lobbystes la
logistique la question des vaccins
tous ces sujets viennent quand même
fortement infléchir l'acceptabilité des
françaises et des français qui
considèrent que finalement c'est leur
seule responsabilité personnelle voire
collective qui permettra de mettre fin à
sept ans derrière c'est venu d'une
certaine manière il faut pas le nier non
plus mais en l'occurrence si vous voulez
ce qui apparaît quand même au grand jour
d'une grande partie de l'opinion
publique c'est que les solutions qu'il
aurait fallu mettre en place en termes
de gestion logistique organisationnelle
de moyens ne l'ont pas été ou en tout
cas suffisamment nicolas vidal il n'y a
pas de passe-droit tous les ministres
respectent la règle lundi bruno le maire
à l'issue de cette affaire
pensez vous que s'il est avéré que des
ministres et participer ça peut être là
la goutte d'eau
cela avec la mauvaise gestion de la
pandémie pour emmanuel macron avec des
répercussions en 2022
bien entendu le son si les ministres
s'ils enquête le dira on verra bien et
des tirs de barrage au cutter en ce
moment qui essaie de défendre les
ministres effectivement aussi des
ministres se trouvaient là dans ces
dîners privés
ces restaurants clandestins je ne sais
plus comment il faut les appeler il
faudra bien moment donné qu'elle est en
dessus des sanctions et des démissions
bien entendu ça c'est important
mais pour rebondir cette question là
effectivement on le voit depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire c'est une faillite
de l'état on l'a vu sur la logistique on
l'a vu sur les masques on a vu sur les
vaccins notamment est là et ensemble
bourbon piétine énormément sur les
vaccins et effectivement l'état
aujourd'hui ne peut plus rien faire de
plus en plus mal les choses et les
français effectivement ils vont faire un
peu comme bon leur semblent ils sont
lassés ils sont épuisés ils sont
entravés ils sont infantilisés ils sont
criminalisés donc aujourd'hui
effectivement face à l'impéritie de
l'état à gérer cette crise sanitaire et
je suis assez d'accord avec ça depuis le
20 ou le 16 mars 2020 encore nous avons
avancé monsieur jeanjean l'isère nommé
dit il j'ai aussi en quoi nous avons
avancé finalement on se retrouve là donc
quand vous avez une impéritie tel de
l'état eh ben les gens moment donné on
appelle ça le gouvernement d âmes chacun
décide pour lui-même de sa
responsabilité à sortir on va pas sortir
et ça c'est extrêmement inquiétant parce
que rappelez-vous nous a appelé à
l'union nationale nationale la communion
tenir ensemble rappelez vous ces
campagnes de communication effectivement
aujourd'hui tout ça est en train de se
casser la gueule pardonnez moi d'être un
peu triviale mais aujourd'hui ça pose
vraiment des problèmes et chaque jour
qui avance il ya des gens qui
transgresseront les règles dans tous les
côtés et ça pose vraiment le côté leur
système de la nation comment on va
sortir cette rue et dans quel état on va
sortir cette crise sanitaire
et c'est une nouvelle fois j'insiste
dessus c'est l'émergence de cet état qui
est en faillite totale alors à grands
coups de plans de communication bien
entendu mais tout ça ne suffira pas et
la désespérance sociale deviendra vite
une bombe sociale pour les restaurateurs
et les cafetiers les commerces ait toute
une série de gens qui sont aujourd'hui
complètement hors sommes et qui sont
vraiment complètement seul par rapport à
cette crise là et on verra bien comment
on en sortira et la question c'est quand
et dans quel état nous en sortirons
voilà face à des gens arras et démunis
et paupérisé un maximum en tout cas
ces sujets sont largement commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux ces dernières 48
heures les internautes qui ont même créé
des hashtag on veut les noms
frédéric jeanjean si il s'avère
justement des ministres aient participé
à ces dîners ça va changer les choses
pour vos collègues restaurateurs
il y aura peut-être une forme de révolte
et on ne va plus obéir aux règles et le
faire finalement un visage des masques
et cette fois ci écoutez on va voir ce
qu'il faut acheter quand même
responsable
quand toute chose dans cette période moi
simplement j'entendais tout à l'heure le
collègue intervenants homme qui disait
que c'est la faillite de l'état si on
peut attendre un petit peu parce que
manuel va croire dit que normalement le
15 mai nous ouvrions alors si on peut
déclarer la faillite de l'état le 16 ou
le 17
elle ouvre le 15 essalouh voix voilà et
va te casser tout ce qu'on vous souhaite
sur des belles terrasses dans le sud et
ailleurs d'ailleurs on espère récupérer
le mot le beau temps à cette même
occasion merci frédéric jeanjean nicolas
vidal et arnaud benedetti d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france